Courtney is with us in Canada hi
Courtney how are you I'm well thank how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I just want to thank you for the work
you've done with the radio broadcast and
the money makeover program it's made a
huge amount of difference and mine and
my husband's life thank you okay so my
question is or my issue is that my
husband and I are currently having a
disagreement about what should happen
with our overtime money we're currently
on baby steps number four so we have our
debt paid off in our emergency fund is
ready to ready to go now he sees the
overtime money I have extra money for us
to have some funds and Recreation and
I'm looking at it as extra boost towards
our financial goals and we just kind of
mediate you're both wrong your overtime
money is just your money all money
coming in needs an assignment it's not
different because it's overtime money
it's just money okay and so you put the
top of your budget and in your budget
you need to have some financial goals
that are boosted and in your budget you
need to have some fun it may or may not
equal it may or may not equal something
around what the retirement what the
overtime happens to be but we're not
gonna earmark overtime as a separate
category somehow it's just money and you
just put the top of your budget and then
you go in our budget we're gonna boost
our financial goals four five six we're
gonna in our budget buy a couch and our
budget we're gonna go on vacation in our
budget we're gonna have some fun and
we're both gonna be in agreement on that
on what amount goes to each and then
that's a different fight maybe that you
have but the what's causing your fight
here is is like you both feeling that
somebody feels entitled to this this
niche of money that you set off to the
side somehow and when you don't set it
off to the side anymore changes the
argument to the budget overall what are
our goals and everything we consume with
fun slows down investing
and everything we put it investing slows
down the fund so we need to be doing
some of both and baby steps four five
six but it is not separate money it is
just part of your budget that's all it
is
hey thanks for the call that's a really
good question by the way